I’m getting older, which would be fine if
it weren’t for the fact that everything
hurts and suddenly I need to nap all the time.
Why body, why?
Hi everyone, Julian here for DNews.
You may have heard the myth that the human
body essentially replaces itself every 7 years.
While that’s not strictly correct, I think
I see the kernel of truth at the heart of
this myth: most of your body’s cells replace
themselves over time.
According to the Science Museum in London
- in the time it takes to say this sentence,
50 million of my roughly 75 trillion cells
will have died and been replaced.
They do it at different rates though, with
skin cells dying off after two or three weeks
while white blood cells can live for an entire
year.
So if most of you is hitting the refresh button
all the time, why do our bodies still deteriorate?
Scientists from the Salk Institute and the
Chinese Academy of Sciences think they’re
onto an answer.
They were looking into the underlying causes
of Werner Syndrome, which causes premature
aging and a whole host of disorders normally
associated with people much older.
About 1 in 20,000 people in the U.S. have
it, and they are prone to early onset of cataracts,
osteoporosis, and some cancers.
Many of them die in their 40s or early 50s.
Werner syndrome is associated with a mutation
in the WRN gene.
For most people, the gene codes an enzyme
that keeps DNA structured soundly.
But with the mutation, the WRN protein isn’t
made properly and it affects the way the DNA
bundles itself.
We’re all familiar with the double helix
shape of DNA, but there’s more to it than
that.
If you were to stretch out the DNA from just
one cell, it would be about 2 meters long.
To be able to cram all this into just the
nucleus, DNA is packaged into chromatins.
Euchromatin is looser, it looks like beads
on a string, and this shape makes it easy
for enzymes to access and code more proteins.
Heterochromatin is more tightly bunched and
folded, which means the genes tucked in there
aren’t being expressed.
That’s why the vast majority of your cells
have nearly identical DNA but they do very
different jobs.
Heterochromatin is folded differently from
one type of cell to another, and the way it’s
bunched determines what genes are switched
off.
This way the cell saves energy and only does
the job it’s specified for.
The researchers mimicked Werner syndrome by
deleting the WRN gene in healthy stem cells
and letting the DNA carry on as usual.
Without the WRN protein to interact with the
markers on the heterochromatin called epigenetic
tags, the scientists found the heterochromatin
started bunching differently and the cells
aged faster.
This could be expanded beyond just people
with Werner syndrome: it’s possible the
heterochromatin shapes change over our lifetimes
after being wound into chromosomes and replicated
and divided over and over.
Maybe this is what makes our DNA express itself
differently and causes our slow decline into
brittle old meat sacks.
And if that’s the case, maybe it’s possible
to stop or even reverse the aging process,
provided we can also solve a few other problems
father time throws at your DNA like your telomeres
shortening.
Telomeres are long tags at the end of chromosomes
that don’t actually code any proteins.
They give the machinery that copies DNA a
foothold but they get a little shorter with
every replication.
When they’re finally too short, the cell
can’t divide anymore.
There is an enzyme called a telomerase that
adds to the ends of your chromosomes, but
over your lifetime they can’t keep up.
There are a couple other factors in aging
too, like oxidative stress, which is when
free radicals damage DNA; and glycation, which
is when glucose binds to DNA, proteins, or
lipids and gums up the works.
So if we sort out these other issues our DNA
has to cope with as time passes, maybe it’s
possible for me to be this young and beautiful
forever.
Ok, at least I’ll be young.
So what is it that’s responsible for this
mug of mine?
Turns out it might be junk DNA.
Anthony explains how DNA shaped your face
too in this video.
Werner syndrome sounds like a seriously raw
deal but maybe with gene therapy one day it’ll
be a thing of the past.
Are there any other bizarre afflictions you’d
like us to cover?
Let us know in the comments, subscribe if
you haven’t already, and I’ll see you
next time on DNews.